[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes historienne chercheuse
associée à l'institut du temps présent
c'est les rays est spécialiste de
l'extrême droite et du négationnisme
vous avez écrit cet ouvrage l'illusion
national avec vincent garos aux deux
enquêtes dans les villes fn avait choisi
est bien de nous livrer une plongée au
coeur des nains beaumont hayange et
beaucaire sous forme de roman photo
quand vous voyez marine le pen au second
tour sans susciter finalement les mois
qu'on avait pu connaître en 2002 avec
jean marie le pen qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
de l'étonnement c'est à dire que c'est
vrai pour rappeler brièvement les faits
en 2002 jean marie le pen est élue mais
à la surprise générale il obtient 16,9
pour cent des voix mais c'est vrai qu'on
les citoyens français le monde politique
est en émoi les intellectuels et caetera
et très très vite quelques heures après
quelques minutes après la promulgation
des résultats il y à des manifestations
qui s'organise dans les rues de paris et
dans d'autres rues et évidemment donc le
parti s'est banalisé est-ce que c'est ce
travail de diabolisation qui a porté ses
fruits qui conduit à cette situation
bien sûr c'est déjà ça alors la grosse
différence c'est aussi que tout le monde
s'attendait à cette seconde place alors
après avec un résultat plus ou moins
élevés ou différent de celui de celui
qui est là mais il ya déjà cet aspect on
s'attendait à cette élection après oui
bien sûr et on le voit bien parce que
vous dites le parti s'est banalisé il a
été dé diaboliser est-ce que vous pouvez
employer cette expression de
lepénisation des esprits c'est ce qu'on
avait dit aussi à un moment qui est
présente depuis peut-être aussi la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy qui avait
été très à droite en 2007 alors
lepénisation des esprits j'irais pas
jusqu'a là c'est vrai que cette campagne
ait eu nicolas sarkozy n'en n'aient pas
fait mystère il avait pris les mots du
front national pour séduire ses
électeurs et ça avait fonctionné
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça exactement ce
qui se passe c'est que marine le pen son
parti prend de plus en plus de place
d'audience déjà parce qu'elle présente
un et par cette banalisation
cette dédiabolisation mais aussi par ce
que ne font pas les partis traditionnels
et c'est ce qui se révèle aussi dans ce
premier tour c'est à dire cette
disparition des deux partis principaux
sous la vème république
alors marine le pen réalisé un score
historique avec 64 millions de voix soit
1,22 million de bulletins
supplémentaires quels sont les ressorts
des électeurs est ce qu'ils ont dans
leur motivation de vote évoluer
également par rapport aux dernières
élections
je pense que ce qui est principal vous
savez il ya toujours cette distinction
entre le vote d'adhésion et le vote de
rejet
c'est vrai qu'on en sait aujourd'hui que
l'adhésion et le rejet se rejoignent
alors que par exemple dans les années
2000 le vote de rejet était principal
voyez donc il ya déjà ça mais il ya
aussi évidemment d'autres catégories de
population qui entendent marine le pen
autrement et qui votent pour ce parti et
je pense notamment aux ouvriers
ça c'est ça a commencé dans les années
90 à la présidentielle de 95 et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça s'est
accentué mais vous voyez bien aussi les
résultats de ce premier tour les
territoires ruraux commence à être
acquis à ce vote fn et c'est un exutoire
où il ya d'autres catégories qui s'ouvre
votre front national il faut pas
l'oublier
justement vous parlez de ces territoires
oubliés c'est son discours elle
s'adresse à cette france est d oublier l
arrive en première position dans 47
départements 216 la circonscription il y
a certains scores inédits notamment pour
l'outre-mer la corse
quelle lecture justement faites vous
cette nouvelle implantation géographique
du front national cette lecture c'est
que le front national est en train de
réussir un c'est paris c'est à dire
d'avoir cette entente
ouais c'est réception auprès d'autres
territoires mais aussi auprès d'autres
populations comme je disais précédemment
c'est vrai que elle a un discours qui
s'élargit quand on lit ces 144
engagement on voit bien que s'est
adressé à ce peuple comme elle l'appelle
de droite à ce peuple de gauche est
évidemment aussi à ce peuple originel
qui est l'extrême rock radical au sein
de son parti et vous voyez il ya cette
audience qui s'accroît aussi par ces
différentes mesures qui sont ciblés
sedif
entre paroles qu'ils entendent bien sûr
et ses différents territoires
on voit son choix de stratégie d'une
campagne très proches du terrain très
actif dans cet entre deux tours vous qui
avez parlé justement à ces électeurs qui
votent fn à ses habitants qui sont gérés
par des municipalités frontiste que vous
ont-ils dit justement je pense par
exemple aux habitants d'hénin-beaumont
puisqu'elle était là bas dimanche soir
j'ai pensé à eux évidemment qu'est ce
qu'ils nous ont dit ils nous ont dit
déjà que c'était pour eux un nouveau
parti ça c'est très intéressant envoyé
puisque pour eux le front national de
jean marie le pen n'existe plus avec
celui de marine le pen donc ça c'est la
première chose la seconde chose aussi
qui l'ont souligné c'est qu'ils ne
croient qu en cette politique auquel il
longtemps cru les années précédentes
donc en ces partis traditionnels comme
je le disais tout à l'heure et la
troisième chose c'était un contexte
spécifique les visions nationales
puisque c'était pendant les attentats
envoyée la troisième chose c'est qu'ils
adhèrent totalement au marqueur
principaux du front national
c'est-à-dire xénophobie une ration de
sécurité dans sa faut pas l'oublier nous
plus on sait bien que françois hollande
est intervenu en cet après midi pour
mettre en garde emmanuel macron rien
n'est fait ils voyaient leur attention
il ya cette victoire possible selon vous
de marine le pen au second tour
le soir de l'élection je me disais que
la victoire était impossible
et aujourd'hui je me dis plus qu'elle
est impossible je pense qu'elle est
fortement compromise par rapport au
contexte par rapport à ce parti ce
qu'ils proposent et par rapport aux
quand même à cette réaction à la
majorité des français aujourd'hui disent
bien qu'ils rejettent le front national
mais c'est vrai que je pense que les
cartes sont quasiment jetés mais il faut
quand même être vigilant oui tout à fait
on voit bien qu'elle parle d'un vieux
front républicain tout pourri qui se met
en place autour d'elle elle elle
pourrait quand même en bénéficier selon
vous non je vous dis je pense que non
elle va pas pour moi il ne peut pas être
présidente de la république cette année
mais c'est vrai que si les choses
évoluent ou continue comme ça je me dis
que en 2022
il faut encore être plus vigilant quoi
[Musique]
forte hausse du chômage en mars +1 3%
cela représente 43 mille 700 demandeurs
d'emploi supplémentaires à noter que
cela constitue cependant une baisse sur
un an de -0 9% et justement
j'accueille hotham traduit bonsoir table
avec vous on va voir les programmes
économiques des candidats et notamment
les objectifs de marine le pen et
d'emmanuel mâcon en matière de lutte
contre le chômage de masse oui alors on
découvre d'ailleurs sur leur objectif
est da que marine le pen a beau
régulièrement tonné contre le nombre de
chemins d'air qu'elle exagère toujours
hier encore sur le plateau de tf1 à
l'appareil de 7 millions de chômeurs
alors qu'on est au maximum si on
comptabilise les trois premières
catégories à 5 millions et demi donc à
la bourre exagérer les statistiques
elle ne donne aucun objectif chiffré
pour son quinquennat si elles étaient
des lieux en matière de réduction du
nombre de chômeurs en revanche emmanuel
macron lui veut revenir à un taux de 7 %
de chômeurs horizon 2022 contre 10 %
aujourd'hui
concrètement quelles sont les
propositions de marine le pen pour
réduire le chômage stable et bien
marine le pen elle ne parle jamais de
chômeurs dans son programme
pas une seule fois le terme nets
utilisés parmi les 144 proposition j'ai
vérifié la candidate du front national
n'a donc pas une seule mesure pour
réformer et l'assurance chômage qui est
très déficitaire ou encore sur les
indemnisations
donc ces propositions ne concerne que
l'emploi et oui effectivement et
d'ailleurs pour elles c'est assez simple
c'est toujours la même recette choisir
la france au lieu de l'étranger déjà le
cadrage général pour marine le pen il a
il faut sortir de l'union européenne
revenir au franc ce qui serait synonyme
de crise politique de crise économique
est nécessairement il y aurait un impact
sur l'emploi
par ailleurs pour lutter contre le
chômage de masse marine le pen propose
la priorité nationale pour l'emploi qui
passe par une taxe sur l'embauché des
salariés étrangers y compris ceux
l'union européenne ce qui change par
rapport à la situation actuelle
elle propose aussi de fusionner
cic avec les allègements de charges un
dispositif qui serait conditionnée au
maintien de l'emploi sous peine de
remboursement par l'entreprise et qu'en
est il pour emmanuel macron tan dung lui
compte sur son programme économique qui
permet de libérer les entreprises de
leurs entraves pour renouer avec la
croissance et l'emploi
il propose donc des allègements de
charges pour les entreprises
l'investissement également dans la
formation
il y en a beaucoup parlé avec lui
aujourd'hui et puis également il propose
des protections mais au niveau européen
et pas au niveau national mais lui
propose une réforme de l'assurance
chômage
oui et c'est là la grande différence est
qu'il propose une réforme extrêmement
ambitieuse de l'assurance chômage avec
d'abord une reprise en main par l'état
alors qu'aujourd'hui l'assurance chômage
est entre les mains des partenaires
sociaux à travers l'unedic
il met également en place un système de
bonus malus pour pénaliser les
entreprises qui ont le plus recours aux
cdd
également il est temps l'assurance
chômage à tous les travailleurs c'est là
une des grandes mesures d'universalité
de l'assurance chômage donc aux
indépendants mais aussi aux personnes
qui démissionne dans une limite d'une
fois tous les cinq ans ce qui d'ailleurs
pourrait coûter au passage très cher en
contrepartie et bien emmanuel macron
contrôler davantage les chômeurs ils
mettent en place des sanctions plus
sévères toute personne qui on a refusé
deux emplois décents et bien se verra si
l'allocation chômage suspendu et puis
enfin niveau financement
il préconise une augmentation de la csg
ce qui veut dire que tous les français
paierait pour l'assurance chômage au
lieu de seuls les salariés aujourd'hui
en résumé donc marine le pen n'a pas
d'objectif chiffré de réduction du
chômage ni de propositions de réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais une réforme de
l'emploi qui se résume en un mot la
priorité pour les français emmanuel
macron lui a un objectif 7 % de chômeurs
en 2022 ce qui est très ambitieux tout
comme sa réforme dont la mise en oeuvre
est une véritable révolution et dont le
chiffrage peut inquiéter
[Musique]
gestion delporte historien spécialiste
des médias de la communication politique
la journée aura été marquée par cette
séquence incroyable qui s'est déroulée
en direct sur les écrans à des chaînes
d'info de marine le pen qui a court
circuité la visite d' emmanuel macron
amiens suivie dans l'après-midi de
l'arrivée 1 en direct du candidat dans
marche sur le site de ouerdes poule
alors est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un selon
vous qui sort vainqueur ou peut-être
perdant de ce duel médiatique
aujourd'hui vous lisiez tout à l'heure
c'est une bataille d'image et d'une
certaine manière la campagne électorale
du deuxième tour commence aujourd'hui à
travers ces images on peut dire que la
matinée a été favorable à marine le pen
dans la mesure où elle a occupé ce
terrain de l'image d'abord parce qu'elle
comprend très bien comment fonctionne la
télévision et qu'elle a été un coup de
com il n'y a pas de coupe comme si les
médias ne le relais pas parce qu'au fond
elle est arrivée là fait une déclaration
est la fédé selphy est là elle a promis
quelque chose mais qu'elle sauverait
cette cuisine mais on lui signe un
chèque en blanc mais néanmois cette
première phase lui a été favorable
la deuxième at elle été favorable avec
le maquereau ça c'est comme dans un film
il ya une intrigue ça commence parfois
très mal et puis ça peut se terminer
très bien aussi
ça a duré une heure et demi c'est long
une heure et demie marine le pen était
venu 25 minutes et au départ ça se passe
plutôt mal et on a saisi le sifflet il
est hué il m'a une présidente mais il
reste qu'elle ne s'en va pas et il
cherche le dialogue et au bout du compte
on a cette image assez étonnante à la
fin où il serre des mains
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retenir
qu'est-ce qu'on les télévisions vous
retenir le vacarme du début où le fait
qu'il soit resté pendant 1h30 en parlant
effectivement comme il le dit avec
responsabilité
ça c'est la suite des choses qui nous
dira un effet on a beaucoup critiqué le
retard à l'allumage en quelque sorte d'
emmanuel macron dans cette campagne
d'entre deux tours est ce qu'avec cette
séquence ce retard et effacer ce qui
peut encore rattraper ce retard par
rapport à une candidate on a vu très
habitué des déplacements sur le terrain
c'est encore long la campagne électorale
du deuxième tour il ya encore d'autres
étapes et on voit que tous les jours
filon il va se passer quelque chose
néanmoins je pense que emmanuel macron
là est vraiment entré dans une campagne
où seule marine le pen était entré
jusqu'à présent et c'est dans ce genre
de confrontations terrain que se révèle
d des candidats et des présidentiables
donc d'une certaine manière on ne va
plus parler de la rotonde et du design
des tournées avant que la roue tourne et
on va parler de ça est ce qu'il en sera
bénéficiaire ou pas c'est encore
difficile de le savoir aujourd'hui on
entendait emmanuel macron dire qu'il
refusait et bien que son propre rythme
lui soit imposé par les médias ça c'est
une erreur de stratégie de compréhension
justement du rythme et au contraire qui
est imposé par les médias dans cette
campagne
alors pour ne pas s'être marqués par le
rythme médiatique
il faut s'appeler françois mitterrand
donc c'est effectivement ce qu'il avait
fait dans la campagne de 1988 et on
disait à l'époque combien les silences
du mitterrand était du génie politique
on n'est plus dans cette période là les
candidats ne sont sans doute plus à
hauteur de de françois mitterrand mais
bien sûr qu'une campagne électorale elle
se fait au rythme médiatique et donc
on va le voir dans les jours qui
viennent ne serait-ce que ce soir à
travers à travers le meeting d'amiens
pour pour emmanuel cros un métier c'est
d'abord faire pour les médias d'abord
faire dix marchés d'abord fait pour la
télévision
justement sur ce choix d' emmanuel
macron de cibler les régions justement
où le front national a fait un bon score
est ce que c'était un choix risqué et
est-ce qu'il est en terrain miné ce qui
ne risque pas justement d'être confronté
se voir talonné à chaque déplacement par
marine le pen peut-être pas de cette
façon là mais je pense qu'il a acquis la
raison d'aller dans les régions qui ne
lui sont pas favorables puisque en fait
toute la démonstration que le monde
d'ailleurs les cartes électorales c'est
qu'il y à une france qui a voté le pen
et l'autre qui a voté m'accrocher voilà
la france des déshérités a plutôt
intello peine donc il a en termes de
communication tout à fait raison d'aller
sur ces terrains dans le monde ouvrier
dans le monde rural ne serait ce que
pour affirmer son courage politique dans
cette campagne est en train de tourner à
vue aujourd'hui les nouvelles affiches
avec les nouveaux slogans des deux
candidats ensemble la france pour
emmanuel macron choisir la france pour
marine le pen cas lecture faites vous de
ces deux affiches dans le cadre des
manuels macro on a manqué quand même pas
très très original c'est classique
qui avait déjà été pris il n'y a pas
assez longtemps par jacques chirac en
2002 où nicolas sarkozy en 2007
il est à la volonté de marquer
rassemblement de marquer mais très
traditionnelle les crédibilité
présidentielle
la fiche de marine le pen d'ailleurs a
été plus qu augmenter parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus surprenant on a là l'image
d'une femme politique qui est un petit
peu au working girl certaine
décontraction marqué par le fait qu'elle
soit assise en partie sur sur ses tables
mais derrière il y à l'arrière fond
président une sidentielle cette
bibliothèque que nous avons tellement vu
avec de gaulle pompidou et mitterrand
les prêts nécessaires effectivement on
voit qu'il ya cette dimension elle veut
se présidentialiser est-ce qu'elle y est
parvenue selon vous à travers cette
affiche est à travers aussi sa campagne
elles sont parfois ce qui est sûr en
tout cas c'est que c'est une une
campagne autour d'elle très personnalisé
une campagne électorale présidentielle
c'est d'abord la personnalisation c'est
d'abord l'affirmation des personnalités
et de ce point de vue c'est une
stratégie qu'elle a établies depuis son
arrivée au front national ne serait ce
que à travers le prénom qui finalement
efface le nom son père un marine et elle
y est plutôt bien parvenu on voyait ce
coup de com aujourd'hui comme vous
l'avez décrit avec cette visite surprise
amiens de marine le pen quelles sont ses
limites dans sa stratégie de
communication dans sa stratégie de
campagne sur le terrain dans cet entre
deux tours
le problème c'est que un coup de com
c'est un c'est à fuser un coup on peut
pas faire le même coup de com tout le
temps donc il va falloir inventer autre
chose en plus elle ne peut pas non plus
je suivre en permanence ce que affaire
emmanuel macron parce que c'est assez
risqué ou c'est celui qui s'impose dans
une campagne électorale c'est celui qui
appose c'était mais au-delà de cette âme
qui s'impose lui même donc il va falloir
tout neufs qu'elle invente autre chose
penser que new york times aujourd'hui à
appeler emmanuel le maquereau à retenir
aussi les leçons je signe d'arrogance
mortifère de la campagne clinton est-ce
qu'on est un peu dans la même situation
qu est ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
qu'à sion delporte ça n'est pas
impossible
ça n'est pas impossible vous savez pour
le sont les landes et dans une
fourchette de 60 40 il n'est pas
impossible que tout ça se resserre n'est
pas impossible que l'attention soit
forte
donc il faut pas se laisser abuser par
des sondages trop favorable ce sont les
français qui décide au bout du compte et
ont de ce fait il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses
il y aura ce temps fort dans cette
campagne ce débat un téléviseur entre
les deux candidats c'est prévu le 3 mai
quels sont les avantages dans cet
exercice et les points faibles de chaque
candidat alors d'abord de mémoire aucun
débat si peu de temps de du deuxième
tour n'a changé véritablement les choses
manière générale les électorats sont
déjà bien cristalliser les choix sont
sûres et ça change pas grand chose
alors évidemment ce que l'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une marine le
pen qui est une grande oratrice qui a
une expérience politique et qui pourrait
peut-être
or l avantage est que dans ce type
d'exercice les outsiders serait emmanuel
macron et on a vu finalement que
dans le débat précédant la différence
n'était pas aussi forte qu'on pouvait le
supposer
et puis vous savez en 1960 pourquoi
kennedy a gagné on a dit que kennedy
avait gagné le débat parce que
franchement il devait gagner mais parce
qu'il était là au leader et qu'il avait
résisté à nixon dont vous les sites une
alchimie complexe
[Musique]
bonsoir tam avec vous on va passer au
crible les propos à la fois des manuels
macro et aussi de marine le pen on
commence avec emmanuel macron le
candidat en marche hier qui en meeting à
ross qui a alerté sur les dangers du
protectionnisme
on écoute tout de suite vers le projet
madame le pen c'est quoi
sortir de l'euro ça veut dire que votre
épargne demain elle perdra au moins 30 %
de ce qu'elle vaut ça veut dire que vos
salaires diminueront en vrai ils seront
dans une autre monnaie mais ce que vous
consommez vient en majorité de
l'étranger et donc cette monnaie là ne
changera pas le coût de tout ce que nous
importons augmentera et donc nous nous
appauvrir on a pas celles et ceux qui
vivent dans des châteaux les classes
moyennes les classes populaires elles
s'appauvriront chaque jour qu'elle
consomme sortir de l'europe
mais qu'est ce que cela veut dire le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre
tam est ce que notre épargne va perdre
30% si on quitte l'union européenne bien
écoutez si la france revenait au franc
de nombreux économistes pensent que la
zone euro voire l'union européenne
imploserait de façon non voulues uns par
les autres membres
donc de façon non coordonnées que chacun
retournerait à sa monnaie d'avant axa
serait donc un chaos politique et
économique est bien résultats dans ce
scénario là en tout cas est bien la
perte de valeur donnée par des français
ne serait que le moindre mal
admettons qu'on n'en arrive pas là mais
bien effectivement à plusieurs groupes
de réflexion ont également planché sur
des
are you où il n'ya pas l'implosion de
l'union européenne par exemple si on
parle de l'institut montaigne prévoit
une dévaluation du franc de 15%
l'envolée des taux d'intérêt la très
forte augmentation de la dette publique
est finalement un recul du pib de 2,3 à
3 2 % la première année
et puis une chute de 4 à 13 % sur le
long terme
mais voilà ce n'est qu'un scénario parmi
d'autres donc la perte en tout cas de
valeur de l'épargné voquer par emmanuel
macron aurait certainement lieu mais
elle est très difficilement chiffrables
ans dans la même si radan a entendu
emmanuel macron c'est free le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre est ce
qu'on peut dire ça mais à écouter le
protectionnisme c'est tout de même un
outil qui fait partie de la gamme
normale des outils d'un état un
instrument qui existe partout dans le
monde et qui ne signifie donc pas
aujourd'hui nécessairement la guerre
s'il est utilisé dans un cadre
collaboratif si les pays continuent tout
de même d'échanger les uns avec les
autres et d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
n'est pas défavorable certaines mesures
de protectionnisme et au niveau européen
c'est donc faux nom on peut dire que
c'est un slogan c'est un raccourci en
fait dans son argumentation derrière on
l'a entendu en entier ce que dit
emmanuel macron c'est le protectionnisme
2 marine le pen c'est la guerre est là
d'ailleurs il convoque plusieurs
mémoires ans dans ses tirades tout au
long du discours d'arras d'abord celle
de la deuxième guerre mondiale puisque
le programme du front national on l'a
déjà dit c'est donc le retour au franc
potentiellement la destruction l'union
européenne une union d'abord créé pour
mettre fin aux guerres qui ont
ensanglanté l europe tout au long du
xxème siècle et d'ailleurs certains
historiens estiment que le retour en
france ça serait le retour de la guerre
des monnaies les dévaluations
compétitives
effectivement la perte de pouvoir
d'achat pour les plus modestes est le
terreau de ce qui a ensuite entraîné la
montée dans les années 30 des extrêmes
ensuite emmanuel macron convoque une
autre mémoire celle de la première
guerre mondiale serve de la bataille de
la somme en est d'ailleurs à arras et à
la fin de son discours emmanuel macron
parle des somnambules du 21e siècle
c'est une référence au livre de
l'historien christopher clarke sur les
causes de la grande guerre et les
somnambules et bien ce sont ces hommes
politiques qui ont des oeillères qu'ils
ne se rendent pas compte des cas ce que
leurs calculs mesquins peuvent avoir des
répercussions incalculables à savoir la
première guerre mondiale
et puis enfin dans cette phrase il
convoque la mémoire de françois
mitterrand
nationalisme c'est la guerre disait
françois mitterrand l'ancien président
de la république au parlement européen
pour dire la nécessité de l'europe
en résumé tom et bien emmanuel macron a
raison lorsqu'il dit que les épargnants
pas tirer énormément de la sortie de la
france de l'union européenne même s'il
est impossible de donner un chiffrage
précis
par ailleurs le candidat dans marche
fait le lien entre protectionnisme et
guerre un slogan un peu rapide mais qui
convoque l'histoire pour justifier la
défense de l'union européenne
merci beaucoup tam on retrouve d'ici une
heure on parlera cette fois du programme
de marine le pen
[Musique]
la fracture sociale fait-elle son retour
dans la campagne présidentielle c'est un
thème qui avait permis à jacques chirac
d'être élu en 1995
hier emmanuel macron arrêt employer
cette expression lors de son meeting
arras mais la candidate qui jusque là
peut-être le mieux intégré
l'enjeu des inégalités territoriales
c'est marine le pen alors avant d'en
parler avec mes invités on va tout de
suite ce sujet de manière aussi la
présence de marine le pen et d'emmanuel
macro second tour traduit-elle
l'existence de de france à la vue des
résultats par département un clivage
géographique net apparaît mais ce
raccourci d'un pays coupé en deux et
fréquemment empruntée depuis les 20
dernières années en 1995 jacques chirac
fait décoller sa campagne en
popularisant le thème de la fracture
sociale
la formule fait mouche à l'époque le
futur président pointe le fossé qui se
creuse entre les citoyens les mieux
intégrés sur le plan social et
économique et les autres tenues à
l'écart de l'emploi ce thème de campagne
sera suivie de peu d'effets durant son
mandat
dix ans après ce constat cette fracture
se traduit notamment par la crise des
banlieues qui vient confirmer isolement
d'une partie de la population
une fois à l'elysée nicolas sarkozy
souhaite s'emparer de la question
on va mettre en place un dans les quinze
jours qui viennent un plan qui est pas
un plan comme les autres s'agit pas de
s'occuper des immeubles ce cube s'agit
de s'occuper les personnes finalement ce
plan marshall sera bien ciblée sur la
rénovation urbaine et ne répondra pas
totalement besoin de ses quartiers au
fil des ans la frontière de la fracture
sociale se déplace aujourd'hui c'est la
france périphérique qui est au coeur des
débats
des territoires éloignés des grandes
métropoles où les difficultés
économiques et sociales se concentre une
thèse que françois hollande a réfuté
tout au long de son quinquennat
y'a pas de quartiers perdus dans la
république il n'y a pas une france
périphérique à côté d'une france des
villes une france tranquille non il y à
la france dans laquelle l'égalité doit
être assurée fracture sociale crise des
banlieues france périphérique
ces phénomènes ont tous la même source
le chômage de masse qui touche le pays
depuis plus de 30 ans et en ouvrons le
débat avec mes invités ce soir sur ce
plateau frédéric gilli bonsoir
économiste enseignant à sciences po
merci d'être avec nous j'accueille
également daniel béart bonsoir vous êtes
géographe professeur à l'école
d'urbanisme de paris
merci d'être avec nous et pour nous
accompagner pendant ce débat stéphane la
zone stick vous êtes directeur du
département opinion est chez ipsos merci
à tous les trois premières questions
pour vous frédéric et judy c'est vrai
qu'on a vu réapparaître ce thème de
fracture territoriale de cette france
coupée en deux est ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est suffisant pour expliquer la
poussée du vote front national en france
non c'est à dire que vous avez
en entrant dans son sujet on sait dans
la même phrase retour de la fracture
sociale et fracture territoriale le pays
il est multi fracturée mais il est
tellement multi fracture et qu'en fait
on peut plus opposer un pays à un autre
ça a pas véritablement de sens c'est à
dire que il ya effectivement des
difficultés sociales intenses
elles sont certaines sont concentrés
dans les autres dans des endroits bien
identifiés dans les banlieues dans
certains territoires ruraux mais aussi
en plein coeur des certaines villes donc
la dimension territoriale de cette
fracture sociale elle n'est pas évidente
de la même manière il y a un sentiment
de crise démocratique de représentation
pour beaucoup d'habitants des
territoires non métropolitains mais ça
recouvre pas exactement la même
géographique et celle de la crise
sociale et donc quand on regarde le
résultat du premier tour par exemple tu
as fait la une du monde de lundi matin
avec une france face à face c'est une
lecture extrêmement simplifié qui est
qui en fait il résulte du fait qu'on a
regardé les cas les communes dans
lesquelles marine le pen arrivait en
tête
beaucoup de communes rurales ça fait une
grande place et on a conclu que dans ces
communes dans lesquelles marine le pen
arrivait en tête
en moyenne elle ne fait pas plus de 30%
dans les territoires périurbains dans
les territoires tout un dans les
territoires ruraux ni quoi que ce soit
30% c'est énorme c'est important c'est
grave mais c'est parce 50 ou 60% de la
population est donc partout ailleurs on
a dans toute la france manuel macro fait
pas moins de 20% dans les territoires
ruraux
il fait pas moins de 1 % dans les zones
périurbaines donc en fait la question
qui se pose
elle est peut-être moins de d'opposer
les gens que de se demander comment est
ce que on rit on résout ensemble villes
et territoires ruraux personnes insérées
et personnes en difficulté sociale
comment est-ce qu'on résout ce défi de
créer de la richesse tous ensemble mieux
la distribuer mais elle a partagé mais
ça c'est un autre problème de faire le
constat de la fracture on voit que la
biographie du vote fn daniel baer est
extrêmement complexe est ce qu elle
comment on peut expliquer alors ce vote
protestataire c'est ce n'est pas cette
source de cette france périphérique wii
déjà enfin pour rebondir surtout ce que
vient d'y croiser gély enfin moi ce qui
m'a frappé dans votre premier reportage
là c'est qu'il ya deux façons de dire la
fracture on dit fracture territoriale
met la première carte vous à me montrer
c'est une fracture géographique entre
eux en gros l'est et l'ouest de la
france
et puis ensuite dans le propos du
journaliste et puis dans ce qu'on entend
aujourd'hui il ya plutôt une fracture
territoriale en strates les grandes
villes contre le rural contre les villes
moyennes contre ce qu'on appelle la
françafrique c'est pas du tout la même
chose
or autant c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
aujourd'hui tendanciellement du point de
vue des inégalités sociales et
économiques plutôt une fracture entre la
france de l'ess la vieille france
industrielle etc et la france de l'ouest
autant la différence entre les strates
elle prête à une lecture très politique
qui oppose de deux fractions de la
société française
les élites contre le peuple les élites
métropolitaine contre le peuple rural et
je crois que celle là elle est
complètement fausse
elle est complètement fausse et je vais
pas reprendre ce que vient de dire
frédéric c'est à dire qu'en effet il ya
aujourd'hui autant de gens qui votent
parisot dans les métropoles dia il ya
trois métropoles 3102 métropole clients
qui ont voté qui nous classer en tête
mélenchon est étroit et trois métropoles
de nature complètement différente
marseille toulouse et lille il ya plus
de la moitié des villes moyennes qui ont
voté qui ont mis en tête le pen est ce
que c'est moi qui ont mis un terme à
cran donc voilà on ne peut pas opposer
derrière la fracture géographique on en
fait une fracture sociétale et je pense
que c'est faux et du coup enfin moi je
pense que ce qui explique en partie ce
vote
tuto protestataires dans les territoires
ruraux villes moyennes et cetera c'est
c'est pas la mondialisation et ont dit
les victimes de la mondialisation moi je
je distinguerai la mondialisation de la
globalisation la globalisation c'est ce
qu'on vit tous les jours s'est passé
quelque chose qui nous vient de
l'extérieur et qu'on subit la
globalisation c'est ce qu'on fait tous
les tous quand on passe d'un mode de vie
qui était le mode de vie locale en
bassin de vie etc en plus tôt en
habitant un endroit l'an de consommer un
ailleurs etc et donc on globalise notre
pratique du territoire et du coup il me
sens que dans les territoires de la
france dit périphériques les derniers
territoires ruraux dans les territoires
des villes moyennes
mais c'est là qu'il ya le plus grand
écart entre le mythe qu'on a mais la
france des terroirs la france des pays
enfin cette france des bassins de vie
etc et qui la réalité que les uns et les
autres on fabrique ou en fait on vit
plus en bassin ou vianne archipel et
donc du coup c'est ce décalage et une
sangle qui fait une des facteurs
explicatifs du vote front national c'est
qu'il ya une forme de souffrance et
c'est un politiste bruno latour qui dit
n souffrance spatiale des français moi
je pense que c'est pas complètement faux
la souffrance spatiale c'est c'est le
fait qu on nous reconnaît plus les
territoires dans lesquels on vit est ce
que on a quand même le sentiment si que
marine le pen s'est appuyé justement
pour préparer cette élection
présidentielle sur ces deux travaux
d'une france oublié ce sont des
territoires qu'elle a particulièrement
ciblé ce que l'on peut quand même bien
en tenir compte pour expliquer les
motivations des électeurs frontistes
sion elle a labouré tout c'est en
s'adressant à des cas trio social très
typés et bien sûr mais est là et c'est
en ça lui c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
le front national
et c'est aussi le signe que c'est un
parti qui s'installent définitivement
leur ça fait 20 ou 30 ans qu'on dit que
le front national s'installe bien sûr
mais élection après élection type de
scrutin après scrutin
on se rend compte que ce n'est plus un
parti de bastions il ya encore quelques
années avant les européennes de 2014 et
les élections régionales et
départementales de 2015 or le front
national était fort très fort dans
certaines zones le pourtour
méditerranéen l'est de la france n'est
pas nouveau ça ne date pas de cette
année
en revanche maintenant quand on regarde
le front national de marine le pen est
arrivé en tête dans dix sept mille
communes
alors évidemment ce sont souvent des
petites communes mais c'est considérable
et on a bien constaté en 2000
il n'y a plus de terre de mission pour
le front national là où il est et faible
extrêmement faibles si ce n'est
insignifiant
je pense notamment à l'ouest de la
france à tout l'arc atlantique tout
désordre
la vallée de la garonne et on est le cas
cette année évidemment avec des scores
fleuves dans certains petits villages ou
dans des petites villes et je pense
notamment la bretagne encore quelques
années dans les villages bretons dans
des petites villes bretonnes
le front national faisait 2 3 4 5 %
aujourd'hui nos frais de 10 à 20 et ça
vaut pour les petits pour les petits
villages
ça vaut aussi pour les pour les communes
de taille intermédiaire donc ce n'est
plus un parti de patience pour axe
parler de très bonnes nouvelles pour le
front national parce que pour un parti
pour arriver en tête à certaines
élections intermédiaires comme pour être
qualifié pour le second tour on ne peut
pas se contenter d'avoir des points de
force dans certaines catégories de
français
que ce soit des catégories sociales ou
que ce soit des zones territoriales il
faut être bon partout
emmanuel macron il est fort partout
marine le pen aujourd'hui à quelques
phrases exceptions près comme les
centres villes des villes riches on va
dire pour faire ça elle est forte
partout sur cette histoire du travail du
fn sur le terrain je pense que cette
élection elle est aussi elle s'inscrit
dans ce qu'on a vu au moment des
municipales de 2014 dans ce qu'on a vu
au moment des régionales de 2015
c'est-à-dire l'effondrement sur soi
total des partis classiques du
gouvernement et les républicains quelles
que soient leurs noms successifs où le
parti socialiste
et quand on analyse les travaux que
réalisent les géographes les sociologues
électoraux qui ont travaillé notamment
sur le travail mais du duché par les
militants front national en normandie
etc
c'est d'un parti qui travaille beaucoup
et donc qui travaillent là les gens mais
qui travaille aussi la question de la
crise démocratique dont les autres
partis s'affranchissent très largement
ils considèrent pour beaucoup que la la
le gain électoral il se fait dans un
très joli programme et la désignation
elle se fait entre au sein de l'appareil
je veux pas dire que le front national
fait pas ça mais il se trouve que le
front national fait un travail de
terrain intense et on a vu dans la
campagne de mélenchon notamment qu' une
partie de
le score est sans doute dû au fait que
il ya eu un travail de terrain sur
internet est en réalité dans le terrain
physique que les autres partis ont eu
plus de difficultés à faire pour plein
de raisons mais sans doute aussi par un
espèce d'atavisme d'appareils on voyait
dans le reportage daniel verdes de
mounir souci on entendait françois
hollande défection qui réfutait cette
notion de de france périphérique et
pourtant je rappeler un cette
interruption ce retour de cette notion
de fracture sociale dans le discours
notamment d' emmanuel macron hier à
arras est ce que ça veut dire aussi
qu'il ya quand même des politiques
successifs ayant échoué à la résorber
cette fracture sociale c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui on est on est confrontée
à une multiplication des fractures et
qu'on ne sait pas les réseaux de procès
pas les résoudre parce que on les traite
j'irai à la fois successivement c'est à
dire que il ya eu quand on évoquait tout
à l'heure jacques chirac et à la
fracture territoriale à la superposition
fracture sociale fracture territoriale
c'était plutôt au sein des villes
c'était la crise des banlieues
donc on a eu un long moment où on fait
la fracture elle était focalisé à cet
endroit là puis ensuite on a dit la
facture entre la france et des
métropoles et la france périphérique et
donc à chaque fois on change et on y ait
une espèce de course poursuite à dire où
seraient les victimes de la
mondialisation il me semble que du coup
on a une difficulté à penser à la fois
la globalité du processus de de
déstabilisation que produit ce que
j'appelle moi encore une fois la
globalisation plus que la mondialisation
et deuxièmement a inventé les modes de
traitement différencié de ces situations
se dire que par exemple quand on dit
parler la vallée de la garonne quand on
dit voilà les zones de votre front
national sont les vols sont les zones de
forte densité du chômage
oui mais les cesser cette forte densité
du chômage et correspond pas aux mêmes
réalités et aux mêmes explications et
donc au même traitement en termes de
politiques publiques serre que quand
vous prenez en gros le même par exemple
la densité du chômage dans le nord-est
de la france et la densité du chômage
dans le languedoc-roussillon
il ya en fait c'est pas du tout même
chômage d'un côté c'est un chômage dans
le nord-est c'est un chômage j'irai donc
qui semences et des gens qui peuvent pas
en sortir quoi qu'ils sont
assigné à résidence le chômage du
languedoc-roussillon c'est strictement
l'inversé un chômage d'attractivité
c'est là les gens viennent parce qu'il
ya un espoir avec le soleil et c' est
qu' ils sont déçus ils sont déçus parce
que ils trouvent du boulot mais il
trouve pas du boulot pour le couple et
ils se retrouvent avec l'un des membres
du couple
et puis du coup difficultés d'accession
à la propriété etc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que les modes de traitement
par les politiques publiques doivent
être différenciées
c'est ça qu'on sait pas faire c'est que
soit en hi-fi c'est ce qu'on a fait
récemment face qu'à françois hollande
quand il a dit voilà il ya une seule
géographie prioritaire de la politique
de la ville de la seine saint denis à
guéret soit on fragmente mais on ne sait
pas penser la différenciation des
politiques publiques alors il ya il ya
ça en germe dans le discours de
d'emmanuel macron qui commence à dire il
faut traiter de manière différenciée les
situations il me semble que c'est ça le
défi est ce qu'on va être capable de
penser la la la la multiplicité des
situations de fragmentation que produit
la globalisation et les pensées donc du
coup avec des stratégies d'action
publique différencier est-ce que vous
avez étudié cette question de la
fracture sociale notamment dans les
intentions de vote dans les ressorts et
bien des électeurs
oui bien sûr c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sociologie des électorats
on a interrogé toute une série de
français qui se sont prononcés dimanche
dernier où d'autres qui se sont abstenus
d'ailleurs et on a croisé tous ces
résultats par leur profil
sociodémographique et par leur profil
politique ce qu'on fait à chaque
élection il ya des choses qui sont
persistantes par rapport à ce qu'on
avait pu observer mais qui sont encore
plus fortes
très nettement marine le pen est très
largement en tête dans l'électorat
ouvrier mais aussi parce qu'on en parle
moins souvent l'électorat employés on
passe très souvent devant couvrir ou et
des employés sont plus nombreux que les
ouvriers aujourd'hui et c'est au sein de
cette deux catégories quelques ailes
qu'elle enregistre ses meilleurs scores
c'est d'autant plus intéressant cette
année alors qu'elle est jean luc
mélenchon qui avait une autre offre neuf
de gauche radicale qui en tout cas si on
regarde l'histoire politique récente
était censée répondre aux aspirations de
ces catégories ça n'a pas été le cas
jean luc mélenchon contient des bons
scores évidemment auprès de ces
catégories
mais c'était en tout cas bien moindre
que marine le pen
mais là encore évidemment marine le pen
elle est plus faible on va dire chez les
cadres on chez les quatre super g ce
serait une erreur de dire que marine le
pen est la candidate des pauvres et que
des qu'emmanuel makrouds candidat des
riches du système de l'établissement de
tout ce que vous voulez c'est totalement
faux bien sûr que vous près des cadres
supérieurs urbain des centres villes des
grandes villes elle enregistre des
faibles scores mais dans toutes les
autres catégories ce qu'on appelle nous
les catégories intermédiaires les cadres
de maîtrise auprès des fonctionnaires
auprès des salariés en général elles
enregistrent des scores tout à fait
honorable pour elle en tout cas et qui
sont au dessus de la moyenne nationale
de 2 22%
c'est ce que disait tout à l'heure elle
n'a plus de zones de faiblesse à part
quelques petites niches mais qui ne pèse
pas beaucoup et à ça et pour revenir à
cette idée de fracture sociale ce qui
compte le plus au delà des éléments
objectifs comme sa profession ou son
niveau de revenu c'est le moral des
français ya une vraie peur du
déclassement et tous les gens qui
considèrent que leur profession est en
déclin
tous les gens qui considèrent que les
générations à venir que leurs enfants
vivront moins bien que aujourd'hui tous
les gens qui considèrent qu'ils ont des
fins de mois difficiles ce sont des
questions qu'on a également posé dans ce
type dans 4 et bien massivement en tout
cas reporter leurs intentions de vote
sur marine le pen au premier tour et on
fera le saut livrera au même exercice au
second tour et les chiffres que nous
publierons seront autrement plus est
remarquable quelque part parce que là
pour le coup sera pas 30 35 ou 40 % qui
ont voté pour moi une le pen ce sera 50
55 ou 60 % quelle que soit l'issue du
scrutin
mais il ya des catégories où elle sera
très nettement majoritaires c'est vrai
que c'est difficile on peut par une
réflexion binaire comme ça en disant ce
que rappelle ses fans de the stig marine
le pen quand dettes des pauvres
emmanuel macron candidat des riches mais
pourtant y'a quand même ce discours très
ciblée de la candidate frontiste à cette
france invisible on l'a vu encore hier
avec la séquence auprès des
ouvrier à amiens aujourd'hui elle
s'adresse aussi aux pêcheurs elle a
compris dans cette campagne d'entre deux
tours qu'il fallait quand même cibler
ces personnes qui se sentent des classes
et comme le rappelait sa dignité
c'est à dire que c'est tout le problème
de ce discours sur la fracture
évidemment il faut la traiter
sauf que aggravé le constat miser sur le
constat qui a une opposition ça fait le
jeu de fêtes de marine le pen
parce qu'en fait pour construire une
société dans laquelle les gens en
confiance les uns dans les autres et il
savait que ce soit prendre la création
de richesse pour tous la création
d'associations pour de l'initiative
individuelle ou collective en a besoin
de confiance on a besoin de pas avoir
peur de l'autre si enfin pour faire ça
tout ce qui va nourrir le sentiment que
l'autre est un ennemi que les riches
sont pas bons pour les pauvres et que
les pauvres sont des menaces pour les
riches
tout ça ça détruit de la deûle a détruit
l'an commun qu'on a dans ce pays et de
fait il ya des partis politiques dont le
front national qui prospère sur cette
déprime collective donc faire le
diagnostic hâtif que la france est
coupée en deux de fait il m'a parlé de
l'apartheid social est nico territoriale
il faisait aussi en quelque sorte ce
constat ouais c'est pas pareil de dire
qu'il ya des zones qui sont dans une
très grande situation de difficulté
quand il parlait de l'apartheid social
dans les quartiers
quand vous allez dans le quartier
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez calme bien
content ou qu' il ya plein d'endroits en
france dans lesquels il n'y a pas la
même égalité d'accès à l'école n'y a pas
la même égalité d'accès à l'emploi il
n'y a pas la même égalité d'accès à la
culture n'y a pas donc
c'est pas c'est pas un apartheid au sens
où il y en avait 1 année en afrique du
sud
mais de fait il ya des quartiers où pour
une raison d'adressent pour une raison
de couleur de peau pour plein de raisons
différentes divers et variés vous n'avez
plus accès à la république est donc le
mot de manuel valls était sans doute
très fort mais c'est pas pareil de dire
qu'il ya des zones qui sont dans une
difficulté parce qu'elles sont traitées
différemment que de dire il ya une
france et 50 mais derrière france et une
métonymie la france et 50% de français
qu'on dira c'est à dire vous avez 30
millions de français qui sont prêts à se
mettre sur la figure avec 30 millions
d'autres c'est pas tout à fait tout à
fait la même chose que je veux dire on a
un problème d'action publique fort parce
que des parties du territoire des zones
rurales ou des quartiers en 18 des
quartiers populaires n'ont pas accès aux
mêmes droits que les autres et après se
pose une deuxième question qui et
comment est ce que en opposant les zones
métropolitaines et les zones rurales
de fait à mon avis on fait en et les
fossoyeurs de des zones rurales parce
qu'elles ont besoin des zones
métropolitaines
on est aussi les fossoyeurs des zones
métropolitaines parce qu'elles nous ont
besoin des zones rurales beaucoup plus
qu'elle ne le pense et elles ne se
rendent même pas compte que en dix ans
en inde récents en zone rurale un
discours sur le mode mais arrêtez de
vous plaindre on crée de l'excédent dans
les zones urbaines dont vous bénéficiez
on a un discours de charité bien
ordonnée dont le pays auxquelles le pays
est allergique depuis 1789 enfin là
l'idée qu'on n'est pas un livre de 2 de
son destin ça hérisse le poil de tout le
monde dans ce pays et donc on peut pas
tenir un discours aux territoires ruraux
quand on est une grande métropole de sur
le mode mais rassurez vous tout va bien
se passer pour vous parce qu'on crée
l'excédent et on va vous faire vivre
avec les minima sociaux c'est pas
possible c'est pas entendable
politiquement et démocratiquement
vous avez commencé à ébaucher quelques
pistes justement pour parler à ces
territoires qui peuvent se sentir
relégué tenu à l'écart de la république
quel sort est justement comment on fait
pour leur parler moi je crois que
globalement enfin notamment vis-à-vis
des territoires de ladite france
périphérique mais toujours des
guillemets ou moussa moi je pense qu'il
ya derrière un message de commander une
forme de pédagogie du changement parce
que j'ai encore une fois je pense que ce
qui fait
ce qui les déstabilisent c'est le fait
de ne plus retrouver de repères c'est la
fin d'un certain ordre territoriales
qu'est ce qui fait que les villes
moyennes souffre etc
c'est que voilà il était installé chef
lieu d'un bassin de vie et c est que les
gens eux mêmes ont détruit sa ont
détruit sa avec les commerces de
périphérie etc et donc du coup c'est
comment on redonne de la lisibilité aux
territoires dans lesquels chacun vis et
comment on adresse un message de
confiance à ces territoires et puis
deuxièmement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la différenciation moi je
pense qu on peut pas traiter par tous
cette question de la même manière
respect je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de notamment d'or dans ces
territoires ruraux des villes moyennes
je reprends la question de la france de
l'est parce que j'insiste là dessus pour
moi la première fracture c est quoi la
france de l'est et on n'a pas eu le
courage dans les politiques publiques de
dire qu' il ya un certain nombre de
territoires aujourd'hui dont les où les
gens sont partis ou en tout cas une
patte vous partie de la population s'en
va et où du coup la l'espèce de
représentations dominantes que un
territoire qui va bien c'est un
territoire qui se développe il ya de la
croissance etc
c'est pas nécessairement vrai partout et
qu'on d'une certaine manière qu'on peut
vivre heureux et moins nombreux j'irai à
charleville mézières ou à bar-le-duc et
donc du coup que que par exemple
l'action publique les services publics
organisent un retrait en bon ordre
c'est le maire de chalon comme on dit
maintenant châlons-en-champagne qui le
dit et qui est de ce point de vue là
benoist apparu me semble assez lucide
qui dit voilà moi j'ai dans les dix ans
qui viennent avec la fin de l'année etc
je vais devoir fermer dix écoles et bien
au lieu de le faire contre un effort et
fort ses envies en catimini
j'assume et j'ai un plan et je me sens
voilà accompagner le changement
on continue l'analyse et le décryptage
des enjeux de ce second tour car il ya
ces 20% d'électeurs de françois fillon
qui d'aujourd'hui sont partagés sur
l'attitude à adopter pour le second tour
certains ont entendu l'appel à voter
emmanuel macron de l'ancien premier
ministre
d'autres oscille encore entre abstention
et vote frontiste marine le pen elle a
bien compris elle courtise cette partie
de l'électorat de la droite
traditionnelle est catholique
reportage dans la sarthe et dans l'orne
de paris brémaud géraldine ben voilà
[Musique]
à l'issue du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle seuls cinq départements
métropolitains ont placé françois fillon
en tête
nous avons décidé de prendre la route
direction l'orne et la sarthe des terres
sioniste afin de recueillir la parole
des électeurs en vue du second tour des
électeurs de droite vous allez le voir
décider écartelé ou encore indécis la
ferté-bernard ville de 9000 habitants au
nord de la sarthe
au premier tour françois fillon est
arrivé largement devant les autres
candidats avec 31% des voix dans un
quartier pavillonnaire en bordure de la
départementale 3 123 nous rencontrons
claude en train de bâches et ses pommes
de terre en prévision du gel annoncé
ancien agriculteur à la retraite depuis
23 ans il a toujours voté à droite par
tradition il y a cinq jours lui et sa
femme yvette avec qui il est marié
depuis 55 ans ils ont choisi françois
fillon de sarthois pour la suite
c'est tout sauf marine le pen apple par
exemple eh oui on veut causer et un peu
malgré leurs petites retraites
1400 euros à eux deux et beaucoup
d'interrogations suscité par le candidat
citadins emmanuel macron claude et
yvette ne céderons pas aux sirènes du fn
marine le pen dans ce foyer fait encore
peur
cela semble moins le cas ici derrière le
bar le patron damien 38 ans et père de
deux enfants
quand allez-vous figure locale il
détient cinq établissements dans la
ville travaille avec sa femme pauline 70
heures par semaine
emploie 35 salariés ce bon vivant trouve
tout de même le temps de s'occuper du
club de foot de la perte et dimanche
dernier il a déposé un bulletin fillon
dans l'urne pas pour l'homme mais pour
le programme comme bon nombre de ses
clients
il porte un regard désabusé sur la
campagne et la classe politique
c'est que les hommes politiques qui
poussent pas les gens là on va voter ont
même les consignes de vote sur certains
qui donne chauffe ça un petit peu ça
veut dire que ils oublient aussi
malheureusement c'est des français les
gens pour voter quel soin extrême droite
ou mélenchon sait les français on les
met de côté ces gens là dimanche 7 net
on essaie de mon tour
elle ne s'est pas encore décidé je suis
un petit peu déçu parce que le fait que
ce fillon et dit qu'il fallait voter je
vois pas fait a qui disent rien il le
fait dans sa mort mettra un petit peu
mais bon ça serait la première fois
peut-être par bellion ou alors juste
pour leur faire comprendre l onf au
cinéma et le phenom
il est 16h15 sortie des classes à
l'école privée catholique saint jean
notre dame
nous y croisons jenny venu chercher sa
fille liz et son fils jules génie habite
la ferté bernard depuis 15 ans lé coach
sportif et accorde beaucoup d'importance
à l'écologie et la solidarité
j'ai voté pour nicolas dupont aignan qui
alors moi je ne suis je suis apolitique
je suis pas vraiment je suis pas plus un
parti que l'autre j'ai été hyper voilà
j'ai énormément lui les problèmes de
tout le monde et c'est la seule personne
qui m'a justement paru être pleine de
bon sens en est puisque son candidat
n'est plus là à emmanuel macron marine
le pen elle préfère un vote blanc ben je
reste fidèle à moi même
voilà en faisant comme ça à quelques
kilomètres de là dans l'orne
la petite commune de val aux perches et
ses trois mille huit cents habitants
au détour des ruelles à deux pas de la
poste et de la mairie une affiche donne
le ton ici on a voté majoritairement
marine le pen au premier tour
le mercredi c'est jour de marché nous
interrompons claude et bernard ont
pleine discussion matinale deux ouvriers
à la retraite au sens de l'humour
ravageur
on est des tamalous c'est très mal aux
crs révèle que quand on se lève le matin
on dit amal où les tamalous sont en fait
deux électeurs fillonniste aujourd'hui
déboussolés une chose que sur ces
convois de manger sec par qui bat par
l'un ou par l'autre connaît un qui veut
supprimer l'europe y à l'ofce de
quelques candidats des patrons et donc
vous fait quoi entre les deux clans
sérieux encore et au second tour vous
savez quand j'en sais rien du tout je
vais voter mais peut-être blanc autour
des étals les langues se délient pour
nous livrer à peu près tout le même
message
les gens en ont marre le petit peuple
fait partie des oubliés ils sont là pour
représenter le peuple normalement c'est
pour le corps aurait secoué tous
s'appliquent tout guilleret et au fil de
nos rencontres
ce qu'il ressort c'est à minima une
compréhension du vote frontiste
ou alors une adhésion pure et simple au
programme de marine le pen
on s'intéresse ce soir aux propos de
marion maréchal-le pen à la députée qui
a défendu les mesures protectionnistes
voulue par le fn alors on écoute tout de
suite je parle d'entreprises qui ferment
des usines en france pour les mettre
dans des pays à bas coûts salariaux
comme la pologne pour ensuite réimporter
s'est produit sur le marché français eh
bien nous disons à ces entreprises et
nous le ferons que si elles font le
choix de cette caste sociale si elles
font le choix de cette ineptie
écologique et bien elles devront
s'attendre à être frappé de taxes à
l'importation pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
bénéfice à la délocalisation alors je
tiens quand même à préciser parce que
c'est assez amusant qu'en parallèle la
pologne il ya quelques mois de cela
avait passé un contrat avec airbus pour
une commande de 50 hélicoptères lorsque
le gouvernement eurosceptique est
arrivée aux affaires
il a en toute violation du droit
européen rompu son contrat pour choisir
un autre fournisseur qui est un
fournisseur américain qui lui va
produire par les usines polonaises à
l'ortm la proposition de marine le pen
de créer une taxe à l'importation
jusqu'à 35% pour les entreprises qui
délocalisent et réimportent leurs
produits en france
est-ce que c'est contraire au droit
européen bien s'il s'agit de pays
européens comme c'est le cas pour la
pologne dans le câble poule
eh bien ce n'est effectivement pas
possible comme le dit à l'intervieweuse
dans l'émission ce matin car c'est
contraire au principe du marché unique
qui a supprimé les droits de douane et
toutes les taxes équivalente
donc il est impossible de mettre en
place une telle taxe quand on parle
d'une entreprise installée en france qui
choisi de déléguer de délocaliser dans
un autre pays européen c'est donc
contraire au droit européen
effectivement mais que vaut cette
comparaison un keuf et marion
maréchal-le pen avec la sphère des
hélicoptères que la pologne on s'en
souvient devait commander auprès
d'airbus
la pologne qui a finalement choisi le
constructeur américain d'un certain on
se rappelle que c'était la douche froide
pour la france et airbus que de perdre
un tel contrat c'était quand même 50
hélicoptères militaires à contrat
d'environ 3 milliards d'euros et
d'ailleurs il s'en est suivi une
véritable crise diplomatique entre paris
et varsovie
à tel point que la france a imaginé des
mesures de rétorsion se rappelle aussi
qu airbus a voulu attaquer auprès de
bruxelles pour demander des
compensations financières pour les
préjugés
subit en effet j'avais déjà fait des
investissements mais tout ça ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec le droit
européen qui n'empêche pas un pays de
préférer une entreprise à une autre d'un
petit signe entreprises étrangères une
entreprise américaine par rapport à une
entreprise européenne même si cela ne va
pas dans le sens bien sûr de l'europe de
la défense
à ce niveau là donc l'argumentation de
marion dans l'achat de panne est inexact
mais ce que ce sont pour des raisons
protectionnistes que varsovie a préféré
le constructeur américain à l'européen
airbus
là encore on peut en douter c'était
l'argumentation un des polonais ils ont
plaidé en disant que les compensations
industrielles prévu par airbus n'était
pas à la hauteur
il faut dire aussi que le gouvernement
polonais à l'époque avait réclamé des
conditions absolument impossibles à
satisfaire du point de vue des experts
des conditions jamais vu il fallait car
busquin injecte 100 % de la valeur du
contrat dans le pays en investissements
industriels et transferts de technologie
et d'ailleurs et d'airbus était allé
aussi loin que possible et a tenté de le
prouver par la suite
en réalité ce qui arrive et c'est un
changement politique en pologne dame oui
effectivement en octobre 2015 le parti
ultra conservateur eurosceptique droit
et justice prend les rênes du pays et
donc il prévoit elle privilégie donc
l'américain lockheed martin tout d'abord
un parce que c'est un parti
eurosceptique et qui ne veut pas
entendre parler d airbus
ensuite parce que les usines en pologne
du constructeur américain se trouve dans
les circonscriptions de ses députés
ultra conservateur et puis enfin on peut
penser qu'il y a eu la pression
diplomatique de l'amérique
et dans ce contexte de fortes tensions
en fait entre la pologne et la russie
sur un fond de crise et craignent n est
bien la pologne a préféré privilégier le
parapluie américain par rapport à
l'europe de la défense
en résumé le thème est bien marion
maréchal-le pen a donc doublement otor
la décision de la pologne d'avoir
recours à un constructeur américain pour
ses agents militaire n'est pas contraire
au droit européen et par ailleurs si la
pologne a pris cette décision ce n'est
pas pour des raisons protectionnistes
mais pour des raisons politiques et
diplomatiques
[Musique]